U.S mortgage interest rates are above  six percent for the first time in 14  years since 2008. on my finance YouTube  channel youtube.com pacmanfinance we're  putting out a video that explains why is  it that when mortgage rates go up home  prices go down now sometimes they don't  literally go down sometimes it's home  prices go up I'm sorry sometimes it's  mortgage rates go up and home prices  stay flat but the idea is that they move  in opposite directions the advantage to  high mortgage rates is if you plan to  buy cash most people don't do that  understandably most people need a  mortgage so we're going to explain all  of that on the on the Pac-Man Finance  YouTube channel